[Musique]
ce qu'il me croit côté d'eux sinon
j'aime bien ce truc c'est de busta flex
des complots prouveront je rap français
en tout cas j'ai validé il validera
plein plein de gens j'en oublie j'étais
en oublier de la com sont activement et
sa rage est un tronc manie des j'ai vu à
coeur cj et c'est chris macari groupe
iris poker mais c'est vrai on est tous
les noms des gens qui apparaissent dans
la série et que tu fais une genre de
mystère et tous ces gens là pose là mais
stop
c'est un classique d'eau pour la liste
des gens qui ont répondu présent ça va
deux des artistes qui sont plus de
l'ancienne génération mais qui sait
tellement créé tellement des grands
artistes qui sont toujours présents
tout simplement comme kool shen busta
flex cutkiller qui viennent et qui te
font confiance et qui sont contents pour
pour l'amour du rap d'être dans ce
premier projet dernier à temps plein est
frappante atomique enfin et freestyle
tous là tués par un commerçant
ça fait plaisir mais aussi d'avoir la
jeune génération comme comme niño convoi
tranquille qui était un mec qu'on
voulait absolument avoir parce que c'est
un phénomène s'essayer de loin des plus
talentueux de sa génération
hier la craie lui est venue directement
via instagram me dire vague fait une
série sur le rap on se connaît pas mais
lyon se parle on croise mac tyer qui est
une espèce de monuments tu vois que les
gens appellent le général dans le milieu
du rap son prénom
je voulais juste te dire que j'étais
derrière toi qui lui incarne d'ailleurs
dans la série ce qu'on peut faire de
plus grands avec du rap français quoi
c'est à dire remplir des stades
incroyable d'un bon leurs frères rim'k
ya esprit noir howard rail pouvoir géré
chromé 12 la sexion d'assaut avec mike
on croise rémy avait pas de grain qui
fait aussi une apparition
merci beaucoup on croise mr après angela
james cause je leur dis ça m'a même fait
tourner popeye femme emma recensés dans
cinq minutes
abba vraiment parfait impôts payent cher
un régisseur sont qui a fait tourner
tout bas qui fait tourner et soprano on
n'avait qu'à pas la révélation rap de la
mer il ya et fils du bouscat ps crise du
demolition bienvenue dans la nouvelle
émission
mary bale frein driver qui très connu
dans le monde dans le milieu du rap qui
était rappeur qui est chroniqueur sion
aurait elle aime à l'eau frette je suis
à l'antenne la dent direct comment tu
t'appelles d'autres and the sky galop
rendre ou non il ya du monde bon flow
mon texte
bravo merci beaucoup ce qui fait que
valider et et est attendu c'est en
grande partie grâce aux rappeurs et tous
ces protagonistes du milieu du rap qui
ont validé cette série et qui ont qui
l'ont poussé parce que ça c'était la clé
de tout imagine bien que si le milieu du
rap avaient décidé de
de ne pas cautionner cette série c'est
un gros problème d'un rappeur à partir
du moment où il vient sur la série il
amène toute son intégrité et son image
sa crédibilité et c'est pourquoi on a
passé des heures à discuter avec des
rappeurs qui avait un premier avis
positif sur l'idée de venir voir la
série mais qui est tout simplement ont
besoin de savoir ce qu'on allait faire
ce qu'on allait raconter et c'était
normal quoi
c'est normal qu'on les rassure et
justement je voulais te proposer quelque
chose parce que je voulais avec chacun
de ses gains c'était que il apporte ce
qu'il représente
soprano lui va les aider à réchauffer un
espèce de d'image positive et c'est ce
que peut apporter soprano je vais faire
une grosse exclue avec une nouvelle
chanson et j'aimerais bien que tu viens
de poser un petit couplet tout ça la
crimée est contactée à un moment dans la
série parce qu'ils ont besoin de régler
un problème et qui va être très adapté à
ce que peut être la crim je crois aussi
une tranquille poteau et justin du
finish par semaine selon lui pour
rigoler un peu j'espère bien sûr je
parle de l'aide soit un bond de changer
en fait la diversité de ceux du hip hop
français
j'ai essayé de l'incarner à travers les
guest à qui j'ai proposé de participer à
cette série qui tendent à valider une
création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal